you know what is it about uh like the
comedy scene in la and like podcasts
like what's the connection
why do so many comedians have podcasts
because i mean like i said like the you
know the thing like i said
um the thing was to get a tv show but
you don't need that anymore you don't
need that anymore i feel like it's
backwards though i feel like it's the
opposite like you you're
you said it was comedian then you get a
tv show right i feel like now it's like
they start a podcast and it makes them a
bigger more successful comedian 100
because you're already doing comedy you
got a solid flow yeah you know you get a
couple people
and it's it's so you're so in control
over this
you guys control this you guys are so in
control over this right you didn't have
a manager reach out to me
or an agent reach out to me to to get me
here right
you just reached out to me yeah yeah
exactly that's all you did right you
know so
it it it's uh and it's easier like we
were talking about earlier it's so much
easier
it's so it's usually directly to the
customer there's no
there's no [ __ ] commercials in the
middle there's no
b-roll there's no music doesn't take
months to produce
no it's just one day one day and done
yeah yeah
yeah like this is [ __ ] nothing that's
why i love it so much yeah
it's literally nothing out of my day
yeah you know uh
so like that that has given comedians
better result
is giving comedians better result and
better you know
like some of the big communities you
know right now have taken off from
podcasts you know what i mean theo bond
you know podcast is what really right it
took
took him took him off to another [ __ ]
level yeah to where it's like
theo vaughn you you graduated from club
comedy clubs now you're at theaters
look what joe's podcast did for him
exactly you know
and the thing was like the thing with
joe's situation
you know that whole mancia thing had
happened yeah you know
and we obviously all know what what
happened
but how long ago was that it might have
been like almost ten years ago really
something like that that was at the
comedy store yeah it was at the store
but like you know he he he
said like his agents had dropped him
you know and he started doing the
podcast
it was in his is in his control
and what does he have now look at it now
man that's right
the number one whatever in the world the
number one anything
in me like i'm a [ __ ] massive geek
for punk rock
yeah and the thing about punk rock
there's this thing you know
we hold on too strongly it's diy
do it yourself and that's what he did
yeah
then that's what you got to do yeah you
know i mean do it yourself
like that like that [ __ ] model
you know his podcasts still aren't in
[ __ ] focus the cameras still are
blurry bro
i just watched one of his episodes like
from like two days ago oh really
i mean it's just like boggles my mind
like you don't even need to have good
production
no anybody could do it anybody can
[ __ ] do this anybody can [ __ ] set
this up
you can you could literally find the
cheapest mic
yeah cheap you know find a cheap camera
yeah
and [ __ ] do it do it in your bed
absolutely do it in your bedroom
and [ __ ] yeah yeah
and you might make it you might make it
you know but if you stay consistent with
it and
and always stay you know
on top like stay interesting and the way
you stay interesting
is continuing to learn mm-hmm yeah i
mean that's why why do you think rogan
interviews so many different [ __ ]
people yeah he's just trying to like
learn and you know any kind of spark and
curiosity yeah
exactly i want to get that person here i
want to talk to this [ __ ] yeah
that's all it is and and you know to
censor someone wanting just to talk to
people
is the weirdest [ __ ] yeah
well i mean yeah who yeah and at the
same time who that's what's so cool
about another
thing that's so cool about the podcast
is that you could have every single day
you could have somebody else that you're
interested in their
narrow little ex expertise they have in
this world
and you can learn all about it on in one
day instead of like
the [ __ ] if you're producing a tv
show
or you're working on a tv show you're
working on that tv show for [ __ ]
years or months or whatever and you're
only focused on
one one subject
or whatever yeah like over your lifetime
you're not gonna learn that much yeah
you're gonna get stuck in this little
grind of like i used to think like the
movie industry working in the movie
industry and working on movie sets and
[ __ ] is like the construction it's the
same thing as the construction industry
oh really oh it's just like that there's
all just the different trades you got
the [ __ ] electricians you got the
[ __ ] camera department yeah you got
the sound department and they all have
pull up in their semi trucks
and they're all on their walkie-talkies
moving around there's so much and you
bring in the different little things
it's such a big operation and it takes
so much time yeah
damn one moment you can't like for one
movie it's this say like
when i was younger i worked in
construction and then when i started to
work on those big movies
like i noticed it was the same [ __ ]
thing yeah they're all carnies with
dental plans dude
this is just like so freeing to be able
to do this you can make your own moving
documentary in one day
you don't have to edit it don't do
anything yeah it's just like we
literally
just [ __ ] we're just shooting the
[ __ ] yeah man why not super [ __ ] cool
yeah it's it's you mean yeah so like you
know
and think about comedians yeah we love
to talk you know so
write a podcast like perfect yeah and
just
yeah and just putting that out there and
i'm telling you man yeah it's just a
it's just a better model like i don't
know too many comedians
i haven't talked to too many comedians
that want a tv show yeah
yeah right like a lot of the people like
i talk to enroll with like
i mean some of them like they'll do
they'll do a part yeah in a tv show
they'll do like
you know roll you know which is fine
just fun [ __ ]
make that money why not yeah it's okay
to do that
you know i don't think it's like wrong
to like want to have a tv show i just
know
a lot of comedians don't care to do it
because
you know they would rather build their
build a podcast would
make your own 100 100 listeners right
you know on the
regular and [ __ ] ride that out
yeah then to [ __ ] be on some network
yeah where a lot of people are watching
but like
i don't know there's just something
there's podcasts built
builds stronger fans it is i mean you
know
depending on like your tv show maybe i
don't know what you know
but there's there's a lot of communities
that are on tv shows and
aren't strong ticket sellers it's soul
sucking dude to be a part of that
bureaucracy of working
you're like i'm on this [ __ ] big tv
show yeah i mean look what you
thought it yeah is yeah
you know and that was that was the power
that was like the power of what he did
you know like a lot of people were like
oh
you know crazy no one knows what the
[ __ ] that man was going through
so the the fact that people you know sat
there and said the things that they said
it's like you don't know
you don't know the [ __ ] he's going
through let him explain that why can't
he explain that
why do you why do you have the answer
right exactly
why can't he explain that right you know
he walked away from that much money you
don't know what the [ __ ] you was going
through you don't know what the [ __ ] you
don't know
yeah i don't know it's the same thing
and look at him he's doing everything he
[ __ ] wants to do right now
oh yeah dude by walking away from that
[ __ ] mm-hmm
he is doing everything he wants to do
right now yeah
mm-hmm he didn't he never chased money
that's why he's
already at it yeah chase you chase the
money you're gonna end up miserable oh
dude if you chase that [ __ ] money
you're gonna end up [ __ ] crazy man
right
i don't even have a car
i live in a [ __ ] room that's smart
dude i share a restroom with two other
[ __ ] people
you know it's yeah why like
you don't chase it it'll [ __ ] that'll
happen it'll come
you know what i mean it's hard though
it's hard to balance it's hard to uh
you know oh i'll turn down gigs trading
vibes for security
there's certain there's certain [ __ ]
that i'll turn down like that
you know my reps will send me sometimes
i'll
i'll turn it down because i'm like
yeah the money's there but i don't want
to do that right yeah right i don't want
to do that
right just because then i like i'm not
going to give my best self
to this project just because there's
money
in it mm-hmm that's not how i [ __ ]
operate right yeah i don't want to
[ __ ] do that
just because there's big money in this
part
okay yeah no it's not so that do it like
that that's how you
say something crazy i so when my brother
passed
he made me the beneficiary for his life
insurance
and i got uh 75 000 for it
jeez and i hated having that money
because i didn't earn that money
and that money i was like you know i
mean
i just started helping people with it
yeah you know i didn't want it
i didn't want it i didn't like it
because you know like
i thought you know i thought this
i'll get 75 000 again but i won't get my
brother back
yeah you know that's why like i'm not a
money chaser
mm-hmm it'll happen yeah it'll come
it'll you know and i'd rather it come
in you know a way of
that i felt really good about yeah
that's where
that's you know how i would want it to
come not based on some [ __ ] like
oh if you do this some good chunk of
change
right yeah yeah unless i got too many
[ __ ]
anger problems you know like like i
don't want to just like
go in there and be like do something you
don't want to do
exactly right cause i'll just be upset
yeah you're just gonna sit there
probably start steaming
yeah exactly like the money's not worth
it like that to me
to not to do something that you don't
feel comfortable doing
right i don't want to [ __ ] do that i
feel like that happens to a lot of like
big actors
on tv shows and in movies and [ __ ] i
feel like they end up just getting
it you know once they get to a certain
level they just get
start doing more and more [ __ ] they
don't like yeah
and then some of them have a [ __ ]
epiphany like jim carrey
or or dave chappelle yeah and i think
dave chappelle didn't he end up like
doing stand-up like routines on soap
boxes in the middle of parks
like in the middle just like public
areas like unannounced
it was in his control right yeah nobody
was telling him to do it
nope that's that's the [ __ ] thing
that's the beautiful thing dude you know
to have your own control of what the
[ __ ] you're doing mm-hmm
why not and be able to see your see
yourself in your work too
yeah it's it's it's a
it's a it's a [ __ ] it's a power move
mm-hmm authentic it's authentic and
you're like yeah i i did that
yeah i created that i resp i respect
that fully i look at that model a lot
you know like
also i look at you know guys like um
um like donald glover childish gambino
oh yeah
guy does what the [ __ ] he wants right
yeah does what the [ __ ] he wants
he didn't even [ __ ] go on social
media and still hasn't and people love
him
yeah i respect that i can't wait for the
day i can delete that [ __ ]
that's a crazy thing that's a crazy
thing too huh some of like the biggest
people the people with like the i don't
know what the word for it is but
like people like jay-z who don't have an
instagram or a twitter or anything
there you think of them as like the
[ __ ] like creme de la creme of
of their thing or like i always like to
talk about how in gucci man went to
prison for like
a few years yeah and no one heard from
him everyone was like freaking out about
gucci mane like everyone was listening
to all of his mixtapes
like just waiting for the day he got out
and he almost like he ascended to like
some great level when he was
yeah yeah the ones we're saying versus
you're on instagram and you're getting
beaten over the head with their content
or their [ __ ] instagram stories every
day
there's definitely like a weird thing
that happens
like in your psychology when you're not
exposed to the same
[ __ ] from that person all the time 100
i yeah i think that's the that's the
[ __ ] thing
like yeah like dave pops up whenever he
wants yeah
like when he would he like when he was
dropping at the comedy store
it was always like dave chappelle's here
yeah [ __ ]
you know what i mean every time is it
unannounced you don't know what it's
gonna be oh it's unannounced
really yeah that's so cool i don't know
he just [ __ ] rolls up in there but
yeah that's yeah that's you know
i hope to get there yeah yeah i mean
yeah everybody you know would want
something like that but yeah i
you know i i want like all the respect
to myself
and you know i just want to be honest
with myself
so yeah if i don't want to do something
don't do it yeah you don't have to you
know what i mean
absolutely man